long queues for coronavirus testing are
forming across the east of beijing the
capital's chao yang district has ordered
all those living and working here to be
tested
it follows the discovery of at least 41
cases in recent days
i do worry but what can you do you just
have to charge and do what the
government tells you that's why i'm here
i'm not too concerned i have prepared
one week's worth of food at home that
should be enough
the warning prompted panic buying on
sunday the shelves of many supermarkets
and grocery stores have been emptied
officials are trying to reassure the
public saying supply chains for
essential goods are secure
retail supermarket stores community
vegetable shops and direct sale stores
have a steady supply of daily
necessities at least 28 neighborhoods
have been put under lockdown and 1200
close contacts sent to quarantine
centers more than three and a half
million people must undergo testing
three times this week as beijing races
to contain this latest outbreak leaders
here are anxious not to repeat the
mistakes made in shanghai where experts
say infections were identified too late
most of shanghai's 25 million residents
remain confined to their homes
the commercial center reported more than
17 500 new cases on monday
138 deaths from the virus have been
officially confirmed there in recent
weeks most were elderly and unvaccinated
though some say the real death toll is
higher
residents say access to food and
necessities has improved though the
indefinite lockdown first imposed at the
beginning of the month has sparked
widespread anger and desperation
a viral social media video criticizing
the government's heavy-handed
zero-tolerance approach has been
censored online
katrina you al jazeera beijing